I love being on tour I love spending a
lot of time performing with my fans will
ariana grande suspend her world tour
following a fatal bombing at her
Manchester concert et has the latest on
the attack at Ariana's concert that
killed at least 22 people a source tells
ET quote the singer has not made a
decision to cancel the remainder of her
tour their focus is on the victims and
their families
Ariana's manager Scooter Braun has been
speaking out on the pop stars behalf
after ariana tweeted broken I am so so
sorry I don't have words Gayle King
spoke to scooter Tuesday morning about
how ariana is holding up I said scooter
is she okay and he goes no she is not
okay it was very firm about that no she
is not okay
Ryan Seacrest also shared an update on
her reaction to the tragedy they
suspended her tour and about 30 seconds
before we went on the air I spoke to her
managers scooter so she's she's with
family and you know I think that there's
there's just that there's a lot of
question that there's some anger because
this is these are these are kids
meanwhile Ariana's opening act Victoria
Monette also spoke about the shocking
incident she wrote a lengthy post that
read in part heartbroken that loved ones
who came to have the night of their
lives ended up losing them adding hurt
and frustrated I don't know how to
handle this and I can't smile